[Music]
chris is with us in tampa hi chris
welcome to the ramsay show
good morning dave how are you good
afternoon i guess either one works for
me brother how can i help right
so my father recently passed away in
january and left me an exotic car um i'm
in the process of getting it running um
and my question was it's kind of he
bought it originally it's a 1965 356c
porsche
and he bought it originally brand new
it's a gorgeous car um
but i'm 140k basically into my house uh
i was wondering should i sell that car
and be debt-free i'm debt-free other
than the house how old are you
51. okay
uh i make enough money and i think i've
got enough savings i don't have 401k i
got enough in total what's your
household income
probably about 30.
30 000 a year
no a buck 30. oh a buck 30. i thought
you said about 30. okay no no no that's
a little difference okay um so how
quickly if you don't sell the car does
the hot does the uh 141 get paid off
i'm two years into a 15-year fix
you're gonna pay it off in two years
no i'm two years into i don't know how
quickly does it get paid off was my
question 15 years title
no i don't know no you make 130 000 a
year how fast do you pay off 141 000
four years
really
yeah
let's start 30 000 bucks a year
okay
is that worth trading that porsche for i
don't know what i can't gauge in the o
you're the only one that can gauge it is
the nostalgic value of this
the older i get the more something that
my grandpa owned
or my dad owned
means to me
i have a lot of that though that's the
thing i mean but his fortune is i'm
already getting rid of the boat i'm
selling his house
uh matter of fact probably a lot of the
assets from the house once i saw the
house you can't go to pay off mine i
don't know it's just the question of you
know
is that kind of money worth
future investment and future retirement
yeah
i i think that's right
basically this is a this is a
collectible
that in decent condition should go up in
value not down in value i don't think
it's an investment product but i don't
think you're going to lose half the
value like you would on a new porsche um
in a you know you know in five years
which any new cars that way by the way
but um so i i you know you just gotta
gauge out how much you wanna
ten years from today are you gonna be
crying that you saw this porsche
that's that's the way you ask yourself
the question nothing's on fire here with
chris he's doing fine he's got a good
financial situation so there's no
nothing telling me yeah you gotta sell
the car today yeah agreed